en los escalones del capitolio varios
miembros del congreso se reunieron en
homenaje a las miles de vidas
estadounidenses que el club y 19 se
llevó adentro en el hemiciclo de la
cámara de representantes es momento de
recogimiento de cher el presidente pidió
a todos los miembros del hemiciclo así
como a los miembros y al personal del
capitolio levantarse para un minuto de
silencio como recuerdo de los 800 mil
estadounidenses fallecidos por el cob y
19 recemos para que descansen en paz 6
más de 50 millones de casos han sido
confirmados en el suelo estadounidense
el promedio por habitante sitúa al país
en la vigésima posición mundial pero el
número de fallecidos sólo brasil e
india- empiezan a acercarse a las cifras
de eeuu en términos de números hay uno
aún más preocupante
450.000 estadounidenses fallecieron este
año son más que en 2020 a pesar de la
amplia campaña de vacunación pero la
inmensa mayoría de las muertes golpeó a
personas mayores o no vacunadas en
efecto solo y 16 de la población recibió
dos dosis es mucho menos que gran parte
de los otros países ricos y la luz
todavía no se ve al final del túnel
eeuu está viviendo una quinta ola
particularmente violenta y la llegada de
la variante omicron y la cercanía del
infierno sólo añaden inquietud a la
peligrosa ecuación